On m'a demandé de venir ici parler de création.
Et je n'ai que 15 minutes, et je vois qu'ils comptent déjà.
Et je peux - en 15 minutes, je pense que je peux aborder seulement une partie très auxiliaire de la création,
que j'appelle la créativité.
La créativité est la façon dont on se débrouille avec la création.
Alors que la création semble parfois un peu insaisissable, voire même inutile,
la créativité a toujours du sens.
Voyez, par exemple, sur cette image.
Vous savez, la création est ce qui a mis ce chien dans cette image,
et la créativité est ce qui nous fait voir un poulet sur son arrière-train.
Quand on réfléchit - vous savez, la créativité a aussi beaucoup à voir avec la causalité.
Vous savez, quand j'étais adolescent, j'étais un créateur.
Je faisais des choses, c'est tout.
Puis je suis devenu un adulte et j'ai commencé à savoir qui j'étais,
et j'ai essayé de conserver ce personnage - je suis devenu créatif.
Ce n'est qu'après avoir fait un livre et une rétrospective que j'ai pu savoir exactement --
on dirait que toutes les choses les plus folles que j'avais faites, toutes mes beuveries, toutes mes fêtes-
elles ont suivi une ligne droite qui m'amène au point
où en fait je vous parle en ce moment.
Bien que ce soit tout à fait vrai , vous savez,
la raison pour laquelle je vous parle maintenant, c'est parce que je suis né au Brésil.
Si j'étais né à Monterey, je serais probablement au Brésil.
Vous savez, je suis né au Brésil et j'ai grandi dans les années 70,
dans un climat de détresse politique,
et j'ai été obligé d'apprendre à communiquer d'une manière très spécifique -
dans une sorte de marché noir sémiotique.
Vous ne pouviez pas vraiment dire ce que vous vouliez dire,
vous deviez inventer des façons de le faire.
Vous ne faisiez pas beaucoup confiance aux informations.
Cela me conduit à une autre étape de la raison pour laquelle je suis ici aujourd'hui,
c'est parce que j'aimais vraiment toutes les sortes de média.
J'étais un drogué des médias et, finalement, je me suis retrouvé impliqué dans la publicité.
Mon premier emploi au Brésil
était en fait de mettre au point un moyen d'améliorer la lisibilité des panneaux d'affichage,
basé sur la vitesse, l'angle d'approche et en fait les blocs de texte.
Il était très - en fait, c'était une très bonne étude,
et ça m'a donné un emploi dans une agence de publicité.
Et ils ont également décidé que je devais -
ils m'ont donné pour ça un trophée en plexiglas très moche.
Et un autre point - pourquoi je suis ici -
c'est que le jour où je suis allé chercher le trophée en plexiglas,
J'ai loué un smoking pour la première fois de ma vie,
pris la chose - je n'avais pas d'amis.
En sortant, j'ai eu à intervenir dans une bagarre.
Quelqu'un frappait quelqu'un d'autre avec un poing américain.
Ils étaient en smoking, et ils se battaient. C'était très moche.
Et aussi - les gens de la publicité font ça tout le temps - (Rires) -
et moi - et bien, ce qui s'est passé, c'est qu'en partant, en retournant à ma voiture,
le gars qui avait été frappé a décidé de saisir une arme à feu -
Je ne sais pas pourquoi il avait une arme à feu -
et de tirer sur la première personne qu'il croyait être son agresseur.
Cette première personne portait une cravate noire, un smoking. C'était moi.
Heureusement, le coup n'était pas mortel, comme vous pouvez tous le voir.
Et, j'ai eu encore plus de chance que ça, le gars a dit qu'il était désolé
et je lui ai soutiré de l'argent en compensation, sous peine de porter plainte.
Et c'est comme ça - avec cet argent que j'ai acheté un billet pour venir aux États-Unis en 1983,
et c'est très - la raison fondamentale pour lauqelle je vous parle ici aujourd'hui.
Parce qu'on m'a tiré dessus. (Rires) (Applaudissements)
Eh bien, quand j'ai commencé à travailler à ma propre oeuvre, j'ai décidé que je ne devrais pas faire des images.
Vous savez, je suis devenu - j'ai pris cette approche très iconoclaste.
Parce que quand j'ai décidé de faire de la publicité, je voulais faire -
Je voulais peindre des gens nus à l'aérographe sur la glace, pour des publicités de whisky,
c'est ce que je voulais vraiment faire.
Mais je -, ils ne m'ont pas laissé faire, alors j'ai - vous savez,
ils ne me permettais que de faire d'autres choses.
Mais je n'étais pas fan de la vente de whisky, j'étais fan de vente de glace.
Mes premières oeuvres étaient en fait des objets.
C'était une sorte de mélange d'objet trouvé, de design et de publicité.
Et je les ai appelées Reliques.
Elles ont été présentées d'abord à Stux Gallery en 1983.
C'est le crâne de clown.
C'est un vestige d'une race de - une race très évoluée de gens du spectacle.
Ils ont vécu au Brésil, il y a longtemps. (Rires)
C'est la manette de jeux Ashanti.
Malheureusement, elle est devenu obsolète car elle a été conçue pour la console Atari.
Une Playstation II est en cours, je l'amènerai peut-être pour la prochaine édition de TED.
Le podium à bascule.
Il s'agit de la cafetière pré-colombienne.
En fait, l'idée est venue d'une dispute que j'avais au Starbuck's,
quand j'ai soutenu que mon café n'était pas colombien,
le café était en fait pré-colombien.
La table Bonsai.
Toute l'Encyclopedia Britannica reliée en un seul volume, pour le voyage.
Et la demi-pierre tombale, pour les gens qui ne sont pas encore morts.
Je voulais transposer ça dans le domaine des images,
et j'ai décidé de faire des choses qui avaient les mêmes conflits d'identité.
J'ai donc décidé de travailler avec des nuages.
Parce que les nuages peuvent dire tout ce que vous voulez.
Cependant, je voulais travailler d'une façon très low-tech,
donc quelque chose qui signifierait en même temps
un morceau de coton, un nuage et les Mains Priant de Durer -
bien que cela ressemble beaucoup plus aux Mains Priant de Mickey Mouse.
Mais j'étais encore, vous savez - c'est un nuage chaton.
On les appelle les Equivalents, d'après l'oeuvre d'Alfred Stieglitz.
"L'escargot".
Mais je travaillais encore à la sculpture,
et j'essayais vraiment de faire de plus en plus plat.
"La Théière».
J'ai eu la chance d'aller à Florence, en - je crois que c'était 94,
et j'ai vu la "Porte du Paradis"de Ghiberti
Et il a fait quelque chose de très difficile.
Il a réuni deux façons différentes, de deux époques différentes.
Tout d'abord, il avait une technique ancienne, qui est le bas-relief,
mais il l'a travaillée avec trois points de fuite, ce qui était une toute nouvelle technologie à l'époque.
Et c'est tout à fait excessif.
Et l'œil ne sait pas quel niveau de lecture il doit lire.
Et vous vous retrouvez piégé dans ce genre de représentation.
Alors j'ai décidé de faire ces rendus très simple,
qu'on prend d'abord pour un dessin au trait.
Vous savez, quelque chose de très - et puis je l'ai fait avec du fil de fer.
L'idée était de - car tout le monde ignore le blanc - comme les dessins au crayon, vous savez ?
Et ils le regarderaient - Ah, c'est un dessin au crayon.
Ensuite, vous regardez à deux fois et vous voyez qu'en fait c'est quelque chose qui a existé dans le temps.
Il a eu une existence physique,
et vous commencez à entrer de plus en plus profondément dans sorte de récit
qui va dans cette direction, vers l'image. Voici donc "Singe au Leica."
"Détente".
"Fiat Lux."
Et de la même manière que l'histoire de la représentation
a évolué à partir de dessins au trait vers des dessins ombrés.
Et je voulais traiter d'autres sujets.
J'ai commencé à transposer ça dans le domaine du paysage,
qui est quelque chose qui est presque une image de rien.
J'ai fait ces images appelées Images de Fil,
et je les ai nommées d'après la quantité de fil que j'ai utilisé pour représenter chaque image.
Elles finissent toujours par devenir une photo à la fin,
ou plutôt comme une eau-forte dans ce cas présent.
Voici donc un phare.
C'est "6500 mètres," d'après Corot. «9000 mètres", d'après Gerhard Richter.
Et je ne sais pas combien de mètres , d'après John Constable.
Je me suis éloigné de la ligne, et j'ai décidé de m'attaquer à l'idée des points,
comme ce qui est plus semblable au type de représentation que l'on trouve dans les photos elles-mêmes.
J'avais rencontré un groupe d'enfants dans l'île de Saint Kitts, aux Caraïbes,
et j'ai travailler et joué avec eux.
J'ai pris quelques photos d'eux.
Dès mon arrivée à New York, j'ai décidé -
c'étaient des enfants d'ouvriers des plantations de sucre.
Et en manipulant du sucre sur un papier noir, j'ai réalisé des portraits d'eux.
Ce sont - (Applaudissements) -
Merci. C'est "Valentina, la plus rapide."
C'était juste le nom de l'enfant,
avec la petite chose vous apprenez sur quelqu'un que vous rencontrez très brièvement.
"Valicia."
"Jacynthe."
Mais une autre couche de représentation a été ajoutée encore .
Parce que je faisais ça pendant que je faisais ces images,
j'ai réalisé que je pourrais ajouter encore autre chose
Je voulais faire un sujet -
quelque chose qui pourrait interagir avec les thèmes,
donc le chocolat est un très bon matériau, parce qu'il a
- il évoque des idées qui vont de la scatologie à l'histoire d'amour.
Et donc j'ai décidé de faire ces images,
et elles étaient très grandes, donc vous deviez vous en éloigner pour pouvoir les voir.
Donc, on les appelle les Images de Chocolat.
Freud pourrait probablement expliquer mieux que moi le chocolat Il a été le premier sujet.
Et Jackson Pollock aussi.
Les images de foules sont particulièrement intéressantes,
parce que, vous savez, vous allez à cette -
vous essayez de comprendre le point où quelque chose que vous pouvez définir très facilement,
comme un visage, devient juste une texture.
"Paparazzi".
J'ai utilisé la poussière du Whitney Museum pour représenter certaines pièces de leur collection.
Et j'ai choisi des pièces minimalistes parce qu'elles parlent de spécificité.
Et vous représentez ça avec le matériau le moins spécifique possible,
qui est la poussière elle-même .
Comme, vous savez, vous avez des particules de peau de chaque visiteur du musée.
Ils font un balayage de l'ADN de ça, ils se retrouveront avec une longue liste de diffusion.
C'est Richard Serra.
J'ai acheté un ordinateur, et [ils] m'ont dit qu'il avait des millions de couleurs dedans.
Vous savez, la première réponse d'un artiste à cela est : "Qui les a comptées ?" Vous savez ?
Et j'ai réalisé que je n'avais jamais travaillé avec la couleur,
parce que j'ai eu du mal à contrôler l'idée de couleurs uniques.
Mais lorsque c'est appliqué à la structure numérique,
alors vous pouvez vous sentir plus à l'aise.
Ainsi, la première fois que j'ai travaillé avec des couleurs c'est en faisant ces mosaïques d'échantillons Pantone .
Ca finit par être de très grandes images,
et j'ai photographié avec un appareil photo très grand -
un 8 par 10.
Ainsi, vous pouvez voir la surface de chaque échantillon unique -
comme dans cette image de Chuck Close.
Et il faut reculer très loin pour être en mesure de le voir.
En outre, la référence à Gerhard Richter et son utilisation des tables de couleur -
et l'idée aussi d'entrer dans un autre domaine de représentation qui nous est très familier aujourd'hui,
qui est le bit map
J'ai fini par réduire le sujet aux Meules de Foin de Monet.
Voici quelque chose que j'avais l'habitude de faire par plaisanterie -
vous savez, faire - la même chose que - "La jetée Spirale" - de Robert Smithson
et puis laisser de traces, comme si c'était fait sur une table.
J'ai essayé de prouver qu'il n'a pas fait ce truc dans le Grand Lac Salé.
Mais alors, en faisant les maquettes, j'ai essayé d'explorer la relation
entre la maquette et l'original.
Et j'ai senti que je devrais vraiment y aller et faire quelques travaux de terrassement moi-même.
J'ai choisi des dessins au trait très simples - l'air un peu bête.
Et dans le même temps, je faisais ces constructions très grandes,
étant à 150 mètres de distance.
Maintenant, j'en ferais de très petites, qui serait comme -
mais sous la même lumière, et je voudrais les montrer ensemble,
de sorte que le spectateur devrait vraiment chercher laquelle il regarde.
Je n'étais pas intéressé par les choses très grandes, ou les petites choses.
J'étais plus intéressé par les choses entre les deux,
vous savez, parce que vous pouvez y laisser un très large éventail d'ambiguïté.
C'est comme vous voyez - à l'échelle d'une personne là-bas.
Ceci est une pipe.
Un cintre.
Et voilà une autre chose que j'ai faite - vous savez en travaillant
- Tout le monde aime regarder quelqu'un dessiner ,
mais peu de gens ont la chance de regarder quelqu'un dessiner -
beaucoup de gens en même temps, assister au même dessin.
Et j'aime cette oeuvre,
parce que j'ai fait ce dessin en nuages sur Manhattan pendant une période de deux mois.
Et c'était tout à fait merveilleux, parce que j'avais un intérêt - un intérêt précoce - pour le théâtre,
qui s'est justifié dans cette chose.
Au théâtre, vous avez le personnage et l'acteur dans le même lieu,
qui se disputent la place de chacun face au public.
Et avec ça, vous auriez comme un -
quelque chose qui ressemble à un nuage, et c'est un nuage en même temps.
Alors, ils sont comme des acteurs parfaits.
Mon intérêt pour le théatre, en particulier le mauvais théatre, remonte à loin.
En fait, une fois j'ai payé dans les 60 dollars
pour voir un très grand acteur donner une version du Roi Lear,
et je me suis senti vraiment volé, car au moment où l'acteur a commencé à être le roi Lear,
il a cessé d'être le grand acteur que j'avais payé pour voir.
D'autre part, vous savez, j'ai payé dans les trois dollars, je crois -
et je suis allé dans un entrepôt dans le Queens
pour voir une version d'Othello par un groupe amateur.
Et c'est assez fascinant, parce que vous savez le gars -
son nom était Joey Grimaldi -
il jouait le général Maure
- Vous savez, pendant les trois premières minutes, il était vraiment ce général,
puis il est redevenu plombier, il travaillait comme plombier, alors -
plombier, général, plombier, général -
pour trois dollars, j'ai vu deux tragédies pour le prix d'une.
Vous voyez, je pense qu'il ne s'agit pas vraiment d'effet,
de tromper les gens avec une illusion vraiment parfaite,
il s'agit plutôt de faire - j'ai l'habitude de travailler au seuil le plus bas de l'illusion visuelle.
Parce qu'il ne s'agit pas de tromper quelqu'un,
Il s'agit en fait de donner à quelqu'un la mesure de ses propres croyances :
dans quelle mesure vous voulez être trompé.
C'est pourquoi nous payons pour aller à des spectacles de magie et des trucs comme ça.
Eh bien, je pense que c'est fini.
Mon temps est presque écoulé.
Merci beaucoup.